hey I'm Jeff ikaw kidding kidding coin
I've been getting it wrong for like 15
years yeah we go away go away
Oh iPad no my name is Ryan Wright and
from the Jabby koi channel you may
recognize you go by Fey right yes
Fey thank you Chloe people have been
asking are you related Jabby on the
channel he is my younger brother I am as
much older more significantly masculine
older brother dominant older brother
mm-hmm
I always put that B word in his place no
I'm the younger brother anyway we're
gonna check out a video together today
called top 10 horror movie jump scares
the quickie version I didn't want you
know the young one here I'll be fine but
the mom was like sure I still watch
horror movies and I was her age didn't
you know we didn't end up
psychologically all there we fine yeah
that's called denial say I wouldn't get
scared in the green okay good yeah
you
I had a weird crush on her for summers
you're one messed up woman to do this
dear daughter II can't believe this is
happening
I know climbing hands
that scene scared the crap out of me
really yeah
why more WatchMojo was that Kelly
they're quick cuts on Facebook and be
you okay
you okay hmm
you usually like to follow these videos
up with a little bit of commentary do
you want comment yeah with this guy too
scary I didn't think that was scary at
all jump scares are you know only work
when there's a lot of tension so of
course it's not going to be scared now
but some of those reminded me of how
scary those moments were when I first
saw them like especially insidious let's
scare the crap out of me a little Darth
Maul in the background I haven't seen
that movie
you haven't seen it
yeah and the sixth sense yeah when it
cuts up when it pans over to the girl
vomiting I remember I had a dream when I
was younger I was like best friends with
this girl and I know why she died and
then I had to like a venture I don't
know how old like younger than ten yeah
um I failed greatly in my dream and
that's why she's you know so she never
that's why she's throwing up no not now
she's dead she's dead and throwing up ah
that's the worst that is gross you
imagine I could not to just die but be
throwing up while you're dead and psycho
that you see in psycho yes the truth
about mother yeah that moment scared the
crap out of me the first time I saw it
man what's wrong with you I don't know
you have like no emotions in this video
that's what you have shown us that you
put your daughter through a nightmare
like this and then it's not even that's
scary I don't know why you guys are
scared that kind of scared me though
when I was a kid when when Kari grabbed
sue
yeah no that was a pretty freakin mess
where so much channel hook yeah I know
that moment scared scared me a lot mom
why why did that ones hear you yeah
she's supposed to be dead my mom showed
me that movie when I was drunk page
really ah and you're dating my brother
what my brother saw this when he was
probably my age wasn't that scary it was
pretty scary
she might murders everyone in her high
school yeah cuz they pissed her off what
the image you are creating for yourself
is just okay not a positive one when the
alien jumps out that was scary because
the alien at that movie you barely see
you only saw glimpses in him so that was
a scary more like these are good jump
scare moments that are memorable of
course watching a montage is not scary
what which one scared you the most
which one scared you the most uh rims
cheesy anything you need a mat up to me
your mom's trying to tell you
videos on YouTube Oh
we watched the like the real paranormal
like ghost hunting things
ah the parenting just sounds better and
better as it goes anyway guys thanks for
tuning in to the channel if you're new
to it you can subscribe to the Rio
rejects you could check out Fink Chloe I
came a corner full video I'll just bleep
it out that's what i did is i bleeped
out her real name yes just like how my
real name's yeah you're not supposed to
say that don't worry it was bleeped out
and you can check out fain Chloe I'm a
jab eco a channel where wouldn't you
know it there's like reactions and love
yous on there and you could follow us on
Facebook Instagram Twitter you got
somethin vine and periscope we did on
well I have a buying periscope so follow
me there Brandon Jarvis hey real rejects
really would love a shout out you guys
make me laugh when I'm down - woah -
Ryan's weird um master you fill in the
rest jokes to Jerry's awkwardness about
your jokes the girls are sweet and sexy
Ryan you have a good girlfriend never
forget that and I won't told her that
there's more no not cool closure I love
to see more content from you guys cuz
they're just that funny to watch Brandon
Jarvis we're gonna see what you look
like there he is there he is there he is
I mean is that your type of guy Chloe do
you like that type of guy are you
attracted to the big black guy I think
you're attracted to the big black guy
those are signs of something that that's
a lot of you're setting your bar a
little high I don't want to tell you
anything but the word high stimulant
satisfaction comes into play if you know
I'm talking about they I do not well
he's a black guy yeah so he probably has
areas of him that oh are larger than
most hmm really be worried be she's 18
Oh Mike she's going after Brandon no
Trudy has a boyfriend who's your
boyfriend no I don't have a husband yeah
whatever I wrote his name in my diary hi